you should be seeing the
slides now right yes we do
great um so
the first topic is about explainable ai
so the outline of this talk is that i
will first give an introduction to the
topic so in this talk i will be
going through explainable ai methods for
images and deep learning
first um i will go through pixel-based
explanations uh so lima
and shop and then i proceed to the
gradient-based heat maps like credit cam
and so forth um then i will also go
through
brief modeling explain explainability
so how to look into your training data
and then at the end i will go through a
few alternative
methods for explainability first i want
to
say about this terminology that i will
be using in this talk
so sometimes this topic
is divided into three different
categories
and these categories are meant to
explain interpret and
understand ai in this talk
i will refer all of these categories as
explainable ai or xai
uh just because there is a lot of
debates that
uh what methods are actually inter
interpret
uh the ai and which ones are explained
and so forth so i would use only one
term to make
matters simple uh it's about myself
i'm sarah and i have a research
background
so i have a phd from theoretical
particle physics
previously i worked as a machine
learning developer
in computer vision and deep learning and
uh now i'm in a project um
explainable ai project um in my current
shop
at den studios and we are part of this
ida consortium
that is a project that is partly funded
by business finland
and in this project i act as an xai
researcher so i go through papers
and then suggest different
explainability methods
that we could try out and then also test
these models but i can't unfortunately
uh reveal that what mothers mothers
models we
methods we are looking into or share any
of
our results um so
let's start by brief intro to the topic
first
i will briefly explain the deep learning
because i know that not everybody here
is a data scientist
so let's think about the simple case
in the simple case we have a large image
set
and in these images we have also the
class labels so for example
uh there is image of a catch and then
the label says that attach
then we also have a complex model called
neural network
uh and in this uh network we have
millions of tunable or often millions of
tunable parameters
uh these are organized in layers that
are connected
with weights uh and if you kind of think
that what means the training phase you
can kind of
like say that you try to fit the data
into very complex model
so what happens when you use it you have
an image
you give this image to a black box which
is your model
but because the model is so complex you
don't really know
how the um how the parameters are
connected with each other
uh or you can't understand how they are
connected there is nothing
mysterious going on but it's just so
complex that humans can't understand
these complex
models so then the black box just
outputs a result sometimes the result
makes sense sometimes it doesn't um this
is completely
like i just made up this example
uh but very often as i've used these
images very often the predictions
doesn't make any sense
um and there is no way to know that what
actually happened
so there is this increasing demand to
somehow
explain that what the model did and why
it's predicted uh the output it did
um but there is this problem
if you want very accurate uh results
you you want you need to use
complex models so the more complex your
model is
the more accurate it is but the more
difficult it is to explain
so if you think about a simple case
where you have data points
and you feed the line to the
points then your output changes
it's easy to explain that now the
prediction is here because it simply
follows the line
but with neural networks when you have
of millions of parameters that affect
the results it's really difficult to
give any kind of explanation
why the outcome was what it was
so even though the explainable ai
methods try
to summarize what goes on in the methods
it will always lack
some certain details so remember that
the deep
learning models are very complex and the
explainable ai
is able to summarize only small part of
it
so it will never explain them fully but
sometimes
that is enough that we understand a
little bit more
um then these explainability methods are
directly linked into data ethics because
if you can't understand what your model
is doing
how do you know it's fair uh there is
these typical
ai blenders from the previous years
so for example uh google that identified
black people as gorillas and then zoom
with
virtual backgrounds uh that made some
people that were very black or very
white to lose their heads
then there was this amazon carry service
that recommends mostly males and the
reason was that majority
of the workers were males so the model
learned
that uh women are not good fit for this
uh purpose so if uh a good candida dates
were simply
ruled out because in their cv it read
like
women or women's like women's
basketball team captain
and that's why it ranked only males too
high
in this career service and then there
was this
case that for example healthcare
algorithm in usa
that failed to flag serious illnesses on
black people
the reason for that was that white
people have better
health care um so they are diagnosed
more probably
so when the algorithm was asked
to find serious illnesses on the
patients
um it preferred white patients over
black patients simply because the data
was biased
um but it's important to remember that
it depends
what kind of questions you want the
explainable ai to answer
uh depends a lot that what
kind of role you have in this process
so for example data scientists so you
can
kind of divide these target audience
of explainable ai into five different
groups
the first group is data scientists and
developers
and they want ways how to improve the
model
train more efficiently and validate the
results
then there are domain users so for
example doctors and bankers and so forth
that are in their work using these ai
and there it's important that they trust
um
the decisions decisions made by ai but
they also need to understand
what it's doing then it's also
important to know the problematic cases
so that they can
look deeply into those cases then there
is these
regulatory entities and lawmakers that
need to make sure
that the models are fair and that the
model works as promised they need to
also understand the idea behind the
system
and evaluate if that's appropriate then
there is also managers and decision
makers
that need to understand the application
its limitations and their potential
value
and then there is the last group which
is
users
the users the most important thing
in this group is that the users have
right
to know knowledge on decisions affecting
them
uh there is this famous gdpr
rule uh that if you actually apply it
very strongly
it actually says that you shouldn't use
deep learning because you can never
fully explain
that why the decisions were as they were
but luckily this is not applied
that strongly at least no but also in
this group
is important that you can verify that
you are treated fairly so if you get
suspicious that
is it perhaps some gender or racial uh
bias that um that affect how you are
treated
you need to know that what is the
features that cause
this prediction and then you have to
also be able to current
data if you notice that it's wrong
and just a word of caution uh this is
very hot topic
um and as in this field um technologies
come and go
there is this fine famous coronary hype
cycle that tries to
model how new trends always come
and how they go so at the beginning
there is this hype phase where the
expectations are
like um it's loaded with expectations
how it's gonna solve all the problems
and so forth
but soon when they start applying that
they notice that
they are not gonna meet the very high
expectation and then there is a drop of
interest
so the explainable ai is at the top of
the hype
about like now uh so if you read
something about the explainable ai
always remember to read it with a
critical eye because
there is a lot of unnecessary hype
and promises that cannot be
kept so just um
the word of caution so if you read that
somebody is saying that
we can see in the brains of ai or we can
make the black box
transparent or any kind of these words
it's probably
it's very probably to be [ __ ]
uh so i will go through these most
common
methods first so limit and shock
um because of these projects and also
because of
uh personal interest i've been looking
a lot of webinars on explainable ai
and in those webinars it's very common
that they say that okay we're gonna list
all the
explainability methods and so forth what
you can try
and i always look into them because
uh as a research xai researcher i want
to know that what kind of methods they
find
and then i'm always a bit disappointed
because
the methods that they discuss about is
mostly line sharp
sometimes grad gam but that's often it
but these lima and shop are very
important
methods so uh the idea is
that you have an input image the model
predicts
uh that it it belongs to a class a
uh you want to understand that why which
pixels contributed
to the prediction and instead of looking
into the model
um as this is model agnostic it doesn't
need to know about anything about the
model
so instead of looking into model it
starts making changes to the
input image to see what is their effect
to the result and it makes these
multiple tries of this and then it can
make
a conclusion that these pixels affect it
the most
but because it's almost impossible to go
through all the possible combinations
they compute different and
lemon and sharp work a bit differently
in the background
so lima in the park background uh trains
or approximates um the prediction
uh with this thing called surrogate
model
and that's why it's a lot faster than
shop because it approaches
approximately the outputs
better and quicker but the problem is
that the surrogate models
are not always very good this means that
the lima can produce clever
uh results or sometimes it's a bit of
conflict
do the explanations make sense or not
shop works differently it requires a lot
more
trials so you have to compute a lot more
um these chains a lot more this input
image and then
calculate the predictions so the idea
around behind the shop is uh game theory
uh in game theory there is this thing
called
player score uh and the player score
tells that if you have a team of players
that compete against other team
the team either win or loses and they
want to know that
which is the effect of each of the
players to the outcome
a high player score means that if the
player is playing in the team
the team probably wins convert that the
player is not
playing whereas a low score means that
if the player is
playing in the team the team probably
loses than if the player is not playing
with team
so it uses the same tactic but with
pixels
and that's why it has very it's
good because it has a strong background
from game theory
so just to list through the good
and bad uh points of lima and shop so
first of all
these are very important because they
are independent of the model
also they work with different inputs
so tabular data images that so forth
it's also easy to use because there is
many ready-made packages
but then as like as the best
slides are that uh they are very slow
because they make modifications to the
image and then see the results
um and especially shop is super slow
um and also if you use shop uh remember
that it
underestimates the impact of correlated
features
because the game theory uh or the player
score
uh assumes that the players are in
independent of each other then also the
results are not always very convincing
uh so lima is not very accurate
uh to make these explanations and the
shop
uh gives more accurate results but it's
often
not good at explaining um
beyond the the highest class so the
explanation kind of
reduce very quickly then also lima has
these stability problems
that if you add small amount of gaussian
noise to your image
so that you don't see it with human eye
that it has been changed
but the explanation changed that's why
like combining the pros and cons it's
often that
shop is clearly preferred
uh compared to lime because a shop
is more stable and
even though it's slow it's still like if
you need to
um like choose between these two models
i would
suggest that you use shock
but then going in the model specific
models so here's the the idea is the
same
that you have an image and you want to
know that which pixels
affect to the output the most
but instead of starting making changes
to the
input image you actually see you look
into the model and
there you first compute
once the usual uh
the you the first you compute the usual
forward pass through the network to get
the predictions
then you convert uh or choose one of the
classes that you want to
um understand or explain and then
you are backwards calculate backwards
um the the explanations to see that
which pixels actually affect it most
to the output um
there is because this is kind of an
inverse problem
there is different ways how to sum up
these weights um and there is different
uh alternate alternative methods how to
do this
so if you have a problem it's often good
to try out
different uh gradients based methods to
see that which one works best
in your model but this is very fast
because
it only requires one uh forward
and one backward pass and that's it
uh so one example of these gradient
based methods
is silencing maps with vanilla gradient
so it's very simple fast and robust
and then it's often visualized such
that there is a heat map where hot means
that there is a big impact
on the model's final decision and cloud
cloud code means that it has a low
impact
on the model's final decision so for
example here is
images of church structure and manta ray
and then the explanations of these
predictions
but the problem here is that it's not
very class specific
um so saliency maps for cat and dog are
almost the same that's why that's why
you can't really explain that why did
the model see a catch in this image or a
dock
in this image um to solve this problem
uh there is spread cam and the idea
the modification is really simple
so in one part of the network you
propagate back only positive gradients
so those pixels that has a positive
effect
to the given class and the reason
is that sometimes positive and negative
gradients kind of neutralize each other
so now they only pass through the
positive ones
and now there is better distance maps
between
the classes uh now it's clear to see
that okay
these are the parts of the image that
resulted in cats and these are the ones
that resulted in dog
and if you want to find green
map you can use this guided webcam
to make very detailed um explanation of
your model
but with these these gradient-based
models are there is often this question
that
is it actually explaining the model or
simply
the inputs so there is this one study
that uh that compared different
uh gradient based models and compared
their results to a simple edge
edge detector its detector
doesn't need a model or training data
it's very
typical computer vision tactic
and the idea is to simply compare the
neighboring pixels and see the
brightness levels
and then it detects the
borders of the image and as you can see
that these explainability methods
many of them actually resemble a lodge
like this edge detector
so they went further and started to make
uh started to
change the learned weights into random
weights
so they started to randomize the network
layer by layer
and they noticed that some of these
gradient
explanations even though the network was
completely
randomized still managed to make
reasonable explanations but for example
kratkam
didn't work after uh like didn't work
after making these uh random
weights and they also tested this that
what happens if they
train with completely random data
can they still make reasonable
explanations
and they figured out that yes they can
so the problem is that um
it seems that many of these methods
actually doesn't
explain anything about the model it
explains the input
and we know the input so we don't need
to be really explaining that
uh so this raises the question that
are these actually any good these kind
of explanations
uh at least i'm not a big fan of these
because you never know that is it that
your model sucks
or is it that your explanation sucks
or is it that they both suck
so going forward
so looking into the training data
this is called as the pre-model
explainability
so before you train a model you actually
look into the training data and try to
explain it
uh the training data has a big impact uh
on the final model and there is this
saying that garbage in
garbage ouch and the network very easily
learns from the bias of the data
so when you start in projects it's very
common that you want to see
some data so you randomly select some
data
from each classes to be able to compare
that okay these kind of images are in
this class
uh and these kind of images in this
class
but the problem with this random set is
that it doesn't actually tell you that
which ones are typical data points
and which ones are rare cases
for these reasons there is
this idea about prototypes and
criticisms
so a prototype is a set
of images that sufficiently well
presents the data
it can be considered as typical data
points
and criticisms are those ones that are
not
well presented by prototypes so kind of
the
outliers or rare cases
and with this approach that if you
select
prototypes and criticisms from the
imagehead
uh the human can build a better mental
model
of the whole complex dead space and how
this actually works
uh there is two different methods the
first one
is the statistical um it's called the
maximum meme
discrepancy i won't go into details of
this
you can read them in the paper um
and then there is the second one called
adversarial
methods and the idea in this is that
you make small modification
to the original image and this
modification is not
random it's optimized by the gradient
approach
uh where the idea is to
to like to make as much
impact to the um to change the
predictions as possible um
but uh if you make uh such
like multiple of shots modifications
but the predicted class still stays the
same
then it's considered as prototypes as
like kind of like
very strong case of this class whereas
if it's very easy to change
the predicted class so it changes only
one
after one change then it's considered
as criticism here you can see the
comparison of these two methods
that are done for the class banana
and as you can see the prototypes looks
kind of like
what you would think that the banana
class look like and in the criticisms
you have clearly
rarer cases um
but you can use this to understand
the training data but there is also
other interesting applications
for example you can analyze the mistakes
that your model did
so when you notice that these set of
images were wrongly
labeled you can use this prototype and
criticism method
to see that what kind of things are like
typical mistakes and what are
like rare mistakes and then by looking
into that
you have can perhaps detect um some
patterns
uh in their errors uh one
important thing also was that um with
this approach you can actually
find biases uh in this paper
they looked uh the prototypes and
criticism of the basketball class
and they noticed that in the criticism
images
90 of the images had at least one
white player whereas in the prototype
images 78 of the images had
one black player player or more so
um it led them to think that the data is
biased
and improved so because of the training
data is biased the model probably will
be too
to prove this hypothesis uh they went
and downloaded
similar image pairs from the internet
and as you can see these two rows
show very similar images but
the network seems to be looking at the
faces of
uh the players to detect that what is
the sport that they are playing
and black people are clearly playing
like basketball
um but with the white people there is
more
difference in the classes the funny
thing is these pinball players
um because i am not a sports person so
previously before doing this research
i didn't know that there is this uh
stereotype uh
towards chinese pinball players but
that's actually a bias that
um more than one explainability method
can find from the training training sets
um
so this is like uh to find these
prototypes and criticisms
is like very nice way to show that what
are the typical
and uh rare cases of an immigrant
but there is like i would see at least a
lot of different applications where you
could
use this uh then going
forward this is now one of the
alternative methods
so this is not very wildly or
very well known this is a
method called testing with concept
activation
activation pictures and the idea is to
find
biases in the model for example
you could ask a question that is a
concept
called gender and important for a doctor
score
and for this you need images of doctors
then you need to have a trained model
and then you will have the final score
and the idea is that you compute this t
cap score and based on the score you can
say that yes the
gender is important for the doctor's
score
or no and how this work
in the paper they give this example that
r
stripes an important concept in the
class
zebra the setup is that first
you need to have the concept images for
example stripes
you can use for example google search to
find those
the more you have of these stripe images
better but they said that this might
work already if you have 30
images then you need also a random set
of images um that are not used in the
training
and doesn't contain the zebra class and
then you need
the images of zebra then
the actual methods is a bit more
complicated and i don't explain it
very fully but the idea is to select one
layer
from the model then you compare
compute the stripe images until that
layer
and also the random images until that's
like a layer
uh then you try to train a linear
classifier
that identifies uh the striped images
and then the random images then you take
the zebra energies images first until
the layer that you are looking at you
compute um
the zebra images as normal then
in this layer you actually
push the zebra images to words to be a
bit like more
stripy so you use this linear classifier
to make the
images to look a bit more stripy
and then you carry on calculating the
remaining part
of the network then you calculate
that if the super class got higher
values
because it was made more stripy so more
than 50 percent of
the images got a higher zebra class uh
due to this modification uh then it
means
that uh see this stripes
is an important concept in uh the zipper
class
um and so the results uh they were able
to find some common sense biases
like red is important important concept
for
fire engines uh stripes for zebras and
siberian husky for dog sleds
um then there's they also find some
gender
and race biases like these ping-pong
players
that i hadn't heard about before
uh looking into these uh methods
but apparently it's a real thing and
then they find also that there is
a pi correlation um or the
female gender is very important
uh concept for the apron class which
kind of makes sense
and so and also is
a baby um so as a conclusion
i would say that this is a promising
idea but the results are not very
ambitious and i would say that more test
tests are needed to see that if it's
actually a viable method or not
and then going to the last um
methods so counter factual visual
explanations
i would call this a bit like poor man's
what if two for images
uh this what if tool you mean what if
tools are very
important for uh or were very much
wanted in
tabular data so for example if you are
applying for a loan
and it gets rejected you want to know
that why
uh like which parts should change
so that you are accepted to have a loan
and then you can get results like you
need to have
uh more savings or you have to earn more
but with but that's easy with the
tabular data because you have
um you have you can use statistics
to calculate that but with images
it's more difficult and that's why
this method i wouldn't take it too
seriously but i just want to say that
there kind of
exists or what if to offer images
the idea is that you have an image and
then you want to
change the prediction of that image
for example you would want this uh image
of three
to change in d5 then you start
you start making changes according to
this
structure image of five
and start making edits to make uh the
number three
to look like five um and
as you can see i would say that these
results
are a bit like bad copy of the
destructor image
and at least i wouldn't see very much
the benefit benefits
of this but then they use this also for
the birds
and the idea to use the bird species is
that um humans are bad detecting
different bird
species so could it be that a.i
will help them to teach that um
and in this bird data sets there is
the data set contains information on how
the word is oriented that's why you can
find very similarity structure image
from the image sets and then
make very reasonable results for example
in the first case
changing the head will change the
prediction
and on the second example
if you put the yellow dot in
it will change the prediction but
if you don't use the orientation and you
choose
the d structure image randomly then
the results doesn't make any sense so
you get these monster images
and i don't think that this will teach
anyone
about uh the different word spaces so i
wouldn't take this too seriously but if
there is some reason you need to have
this what if tool for images
this is one that you could use
okay so that was all that i managed to
fit
into this 25 minutes
presentation so as the final remarks uh
remember that ai models inherit
and magnified the bias of the data very
easily
and that's why it's also important uh
the both
the training data and your model uh
explainable ai is very important but
it's badly hyped
topic um and remember that explainable
ai
is always approximation of the false
solution
and it always lacks some details also
don't trust blindly on
one method try to use different methods
instead
and but then there is the very important
thing that
if you use xai correctly
it helps us to make better and more fair
models and when
i was going through these um papers i
find one blog post that listed
uh some xai software packages
that contains some of the methods that i
showed in here
so if you want to take a look um there
is the link to it
um but many of these
methods are still like kind of like not
very mainstream
um so you can't find them in the
packages you have to do
a lot of coding yourself in order to
test them
so thank you from me and my home
colleagues and if you have
some questions please contact me
by email or via linkedin
thank you thank you sarah
that was really interesting and uh yeah
uh
really insightful uh so i have a few
questions
uh from that chat uh again if you have
any question you may
ask them you may write it down write
them down
in the chat section uh for you sara i
have two questions
uh first a question from hunei which is
uh
can some of the methods you described
be used to counter some attacks on
neural networks
for example uh pixel alternate
alteration
um so what kind of attacks
can you repeat uh
you may also see it in the chat section
uh
well i'll repeat it uh can some of the
methods you described
be used to counter some attacks on
neural networks
for example uh pixel alteration
i think uh well
if you in some cases i guess about this
question in some cases
you may alter the the image for example
a very
you may add some noise or something that
may uh
uh cause the the model to
uh make a different uh prediction uh
yeah uh yeah there is uh there is some
others uh
can that can do that uh so you can
make attacks to the network uh
by a pro like um
making like calculating the most
effective wave
to inject the network and change this
prediction
but if you think it's vice versa it's a
lot more difficult
to find these kind of attacks um
so i haven't found that kind of
explainable ai methods
that could find that uh now
these images are tried to be
attacked uh with some um some
method okay uh
yeah uh so another question uh again
uh do you think that more explainable ai
methods
should be used to fix models and remove
their biases
or rather inform us of about our own
biases
well if yes it's i guess it's a longer
um question but yeah
so i think the idea is to try to fix the
models
and remove the biases but
about to inform us about our own biases
it's
a bit more difficult because the
training sets the majority of the
training
data is collected from white rich
countries
um so that's why the data sets are often
already
biased and then there is a lot of
problems that for example
if you collect the data uh kind of like
wrongly
so many collect them like for example
using
news's uh news um articles
uh there for example uh black people as
criminals are
uh sampled very high and often black
people are not presented as
uh in a cute glide uh so that's why how
to
how you collect the data is actually
more important than
uh what the um what kind of biases the
people
might have i would say okay
yeah thanks